LEAFS TRY TO COUNTER ATTACK.
LUPUL THE PASS DEFLECTS INTO THE
ZONE.
THE ERRANT PASS.
AND SCORES OF OH, MY!
JONATHAN QUICK OF LOS ANGELES
HAD A BRAIN CRAMP AND BERNIER
HAS HAD ONE HERE.
>> YOU THOUGHT IT WAS ICING,
DIDN'T YOU?
>> I DID.
AND THEY ARE DISCUSSING IT NOW.
NOW YOU DON'T HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL
SOMEBODY TOUCH ITS.
>> I THINK HE JUST MISS PLAYED
IT.
>> IT WAS NOT TOUCHED I BELIEVE.
>> IT'S ICING AND YOU CAN SEE
THE THE REACTION ON THE PLAY.
TAKES HIS EYES OFF THE PUCK FOR
A MINUTE.
>> THE LINES MAN WAVED IT OFF.
NO ICING.
MY GOOD JOONS IT F IT HITS
A STICK ON THE WAY IT'S
DIFFERENT.
BUT IF IT DOESN'T.
>> RANDY IS GOING TO GET THE
EXPLANATION FROM BRAD WATSON.
JO ISN'T IT IF THE GOALIE COMES
OUT THE ICE SUGGEST WAVED OFF?
>> NEVERAP ISSUE THAT OFF HIS
FOOT AND INTO THE NET.